مرحباً، اسمي ديفيد براون وهذا درس في النطق.
مرحباً، أهلاً بك. كيف حالك؟
مرحباً، شكراً لك. أنا بخير. وأنت؟
أنا بخير جداً. شكراً لك. ما اسمك؟
اسمي لورديس (Lūrdis). لورديس لاندا.
مرحباً يا آنسة لورديس. أهلاً بك. أنا الأستاذ براون. من أين أنتِ؟
أنا من تيغوسيغالبا، هندوراس.
حسناً، تيغوسيغالبا. رائع. زوجتي من تيغوسيغالبا.
أوه، هذا لطيف.
نعم، سررت بلقائك.
وأنا أيضاً سررت بلقائك.
أرى أنكِ اخترتِ درساً عن أصوات TH المختلفة هذه. هل هذا مناسب؟
نعم، هذا صحيح.
حسناً، لدينا صوتان قد يكونان مربكين. لدينا صوت TH المهموس وصوت TH الجهوري.
كلاهما يتضمن وضع لسانك بين أسنانك.
أحدهما، الجهوري، به اهتزاز والمهموس ليس به اهتزاز.
نحتاج أن نعرف متى نستخدم هذا ومتى نتذكر كيف نستخدم هذه الأصوات المختلفة هنا.
إذاً سنبدأ. سؤال. هل سبق لكِ أن قلتِ "sync" عندما كنتِ تقصدين قول "think" أو "free" بدلاً من "three"؟
أعتقد أنني فعلت ذلك من قبل.
وهذا شائع جداً. حتى بعض المتحدثين الأصليين، بعض المتحدثين الأصليين، على سبيل المثال، سيقولون "birth day" بصوت F بدلاً من صوت TH.
القليل من التدريب. تعرفين أين تضعين لسانك. إذا عرفتِ ما هو الصوت الذي يصدره ومن أين تأتي الأصوات.
يمكن إصلاحه بسهولة. يمكنكِ تعلم سماع وإنتاج هذه الاختلافات في الأصوات.
حسناً.
إذاً إليكِ بعض الأهداف. أود منكِ أن تقرئيها.
حسناً، أريدكِ أن تستمعي إلى هذه الأهداف هنا. إذاً سنكون قادرين على التمييز بين أصوات TH هذه. لدينا الأصوات الاحتكاكية المهموسة والجهورية.
سنصف ونوضح حركات الفم الصحيحة وآلياتها لهذه الأصوات المختلفة.
سأكون قادراً على إنتاج هذه الأصوات بدقة في كلمات منفصلة وكذلك في عبارات قصيرة أيضاً. لذا سنحاول استخدامها في سياقها.
وسنحاول التعرف على أنماط الإملاء الشائعة المرتبطة بـ TH.
وتحتاجين بشكل أساسي إلى ملاحظة وتصحيح نفسكِ كلما استخدمتِ TH والتدرب.
إذاً هو بعض الضبط الدقيق للنطق في درس اليوم.
كيف تشعرين تجاه نطقكِ؟ هل تشعرين أنكِ بحاجة إلى العمل على نطقكِ؟
نعم، بالتأكيد.
حسناً. أعتقد أن هذا درس جيد حتى لبعضنا نحن المتحدثين الأصليين أيضاً. لذا لا تقلقي إذا شعرتِ بالتوتر. هذا طبيعي تماماً.
ولا تخافي من أن تبدي سخيفة. إنه درس سخيف نوعاً ما عندما تصدرين أصواتاً غريبة بلسانكِ وأسنانكِ.
شكراً لك.
تحسين هذا يمكن أن يساعدكِ في محادثاتكِ اليومية أو في العمل. بالمناسبة يا لورديس، ماذا تعملين؟ ما هي وظيفتكِ؟
أنا أعمل في الواقع مع الحكومة.
في القسم القانوني في مكتب.
وهناك عدد قليل فقط من الأشخاص الذين يمكنهم التحدث باللغة الإنجليزية بالفعل. لذا عندما يحدث شيء من هذا القبيل، يحتاجون لمساعدتي.
وأعتقد أنه سيكون مفيداً جداً إذا عرفت الطريقة الصحيحة لنطق هذا النوع من الكلمات لأنه يتم الخلط بينها.
حسناً، بالتأكيد. إذاً لديكِ سبب وجيه للتدرب على هذا اليوم وتحسين نطقكِ.
نحتاج إلى فهم هذين الصوتين المختلفين وما يعنيه الصوت المهموس والصوت الجهوري، لأنه حسناً، في أي وقت نتحدث، يمكننا أن نشعر بالاهتزازات أو لا نشعر بها.
لذا إذا وضعتِ يديكِ أمام حلقكِ هنا، هل يمكنكِ فعل ذلك من أجلي.
وابدئي في التحدث فقط. قولي شيئاً ما. ربما عبارة.
مرحباً، اسمي نوح. مرحباً. نعم، يمكنني بالتأكيد الشعور بذلك.
إذاً ترين أن هناك لحظات يهتز فيها ولحظات لا يهتز فيها.
بشكل أساسي، هذه الأصوات الجهرية، المتعلقة بنهاية ED، هي أصوات حركات (علة) سنجدها في أجزاء مختلفة من الكلمة.
هذه أصوات جهرية. والأصوات التي نصدرها ولا تهتز هنا هي الأصوات المهموسة.
لذا نرى في الرسم البياني أن لدينا مثالين مختلفين، أحدهما للمهموس thick.
ولا يوجد اهتزاز. لذا إذا وضعتِ يدكِ هنا، إذا وضعتِ يدكِ هنا من أجلي وقلتِ، thick،
thick، لا يجب أن تشعري بأي اهتزاز على الإطلاق لذلك الصوت، أليس كذلك؟
مرة أخرى، thick، لا اهتزاز. ربما لـ، نعم، ولكن ليس لـ TH، أليس كذلك؟
الآن، هذا التالي، من فضلكِ، حاولي مرة أخرى، حتى اللسان يهتز، أليس كذلك؟
لذا إذا اهتز، نعم، على طول الطريق للأعلى، يستمر هذا الاهتزاز والمسار الصوتي للأمام،
ولدينا هذا الصوت الجهوري مع هذه. لذا لدينا الصوت الجهوري مع TH ومع صوت الحركة (العلة) هذا هنا.
لذا يمكن أن تأتي بعض الحروف الساكنة أيضاً مع أنواع مختلفة من الأصوات الجهرية أيضاً، مثل هذه الأصوات الاحتكاكية الجهرية.
إذاً هذا هو الصوت في كلمات مثل، think بدون اهتزاز، أليس كذلك؟
Thank, then, back, path و three.
Thank.
الآن، تأكدي من أن لسانكِ يمر بين أسنانكِ. هل يمكنكِ قراءة هذا الجزء لنا هنا؟
Think, think, think, think, back, three.
حسناً، جيد. إذاً لاحظوا أن هذه لا تهتز.
لذا لا نريد الخلط بين هذه وقول، think، على سبيل المثال، الصوت يبدو أشبه بصوت dip.
لا نريد استخدام الأصوات الاحتكاكية الجهرية عندما لا يفترض بنا ذلك والعكس صحيح.
لذا يتطلب الأمر بعض الذاكرة وبعض الاهتزاز هنا.
لذا نتدرب على صوت TH هنا. تذكري، لا يجب أن تشعري بأي طنين هناك.
دعنا نحاول هذا مرة أخرى. سنجرب الـ، والـ، الـ، بالنسبة للصوت، يمكنكِ الشعور ببعض الهواء على يدكِ.
هل يمكنكِ القول،
أعتقد أن الـ، آه، في النهاية قليلاً.
ماذا، آه، أعتقد، صوت TH هناك ليس جمهورياً.
إنه فرق دقيق، ولكنه مهم للنطق.
لذا يمكننا رؤية بعض الاختلافات بين هذه.
بشكل أساسي، هما الفرق الوحيد.
لديكِ اللسان بين كلتا، آه، اللسان بين أسنانكِ في كلتا هاتين الصورتين.
ولكن بالنسبة للصوت الاحتكاكي الجهوري، لديكِ أيضاً ذلك الاهتزاز.
حسناً، إذاً أعتقد أنني شرحت ذلك وأنتِ فهمتِ، أليس كذلك؟
هذا هو الصوت في كلمات مثل، الآن لدينا الطنين.
أعتقد أنني أفهم. أعرف أنني يجب أن أتدرب.
إذاً لدينا صوت الطنين في هذه الكلمات. لذا استمعي إليّ أقولها مرة واحدة.
لدينا this. إذاً لديكِ اهتزاز.
This, that, then, mother, breathe, و they, حاولي أنتِ.
حسناً، دعنا نرى.
Breathe, that, then, mother, breath, they.
جيد. هذا هنا. Breathe, breathe, breathe, breathe.
جيد. Breathe.
هاه؟ إذاً لاحظوا أن الاهتزاز هناك يجب أن يكون مثل صوت، مثل طنين.
Breathe. جيد.
أفضل بكثير.
أعتقد أنكِ ترين الخوف من إصدار الصوت الآخر.
مثال آخر لبعض الأصوات التي لها صوت جهوري سيكون مثل حرف S.
أحياناً يصدر صوتاً أيضاً، مقابل ذلك الصوت المهموس.
إذاً هذا هو الفرق الوحيد هناك.